this is evan langer reading for reviewer
justin clark the greatest compliment one
can pay to weird west is that it does by
and large capture the feeling of playing
one of the pulpy ec comics and two
fisted tales that inspired so many
supernatural westerns in the past
from its beautiful two color art style
and creepy morality fables to its
omnipresent leathery sounding narrator
weird west is a fully realized grungy
dime store cowboy fantasy brought to
vivid life
the game you actually have to play to
make progress in it isn't as resounding
a success however the pistol's grip
matches your palm exactly
all blue
been a while
weird west wastes no time knocking you
off kilter the second you hit the new
game option you an unnamed hooded figure
are strapped to a chair while other
hooded figures brand your neck with an
arcane symbol and shove you into the
body of one jane bell a former bounty
hunter who's hung up her spurs for the
quiet life on a farm
unfortunately she's forced to go full
unforgiven after a gang called the still
waters raids her farm kills her children
and kidnaps her husband as it turns out
they've been raiding towns and villages
across the country looking for fresh
meat to feed their new skinwalker
leaders and it's up to jane to put a
stop to their reign of terror weird west
is an anthology so when jane's story has
come to a close we find ourselves
putting the brand on someone new and
when you're done playing through that
tale there are three more waiting for
you
the weird west is a place with a memory
however so someone you kill as jane bell
is still a goner when the next character
shows up though there's a non-zero
chance you see them later as a zombie or
a ghost with unfinished business
if jane hasn't yet captured a specific
criminal when her story is over that
criminal will continue to operate until
you no matter whose body you inhabit
finally take the time to put them down
choosing not to kill someone can have an
impact as well if you save someone's
life they may show up later during a
shootout to save you in return
on paper that level of cause and effect
sounds incredible but weird west is a
few rounds shy of a loaded revolver as
the morality system by which many of the
game's decisions are made is far too
binary to live up to the game's
complexity elsewhere most of the game's
choices come down to either the saintly
right thing or such cartoonish mustache
twirling evil that at times it's almost
appalling that the option exists
in one particular moment where you
confront a woman who betrayed your
character for the best possible reason
the evil option is so abominable it
deserves a trigger warning yes the
correct choice is still there and
handled well but the stories of our main
characters are strong enough on their
own
they allow this group of marginalized
folks to examine their roles in creating
and surviving an increasingly colonized
and haunted west and all the ways
manifest destiny makes an already
terrifying place even scarier some
choices like whether to assist a
recurring character who's traveling the
west in search of the keys to
immortality actually say something
worthwhile
most however lack narrative nuance and
come down to killing or sparing someone
even in those cases death has a
compelling ripple effect on the world a
dead marauder sibling might be waiting
for you outside of town
wiping a town clean of one gang may
leave it wide open to be occupied by
their enemies next time you visit the
storytelling as a whole is simplistic
mostly go here talk to this person kill
that person's scenarios but that's not
necessarily a bad thing on its own
especially when the dialogue for these
scenarios is so well written it's a
wonderful mashup that sees grizzled
brash wild west dialogue clash against
eldritch cosmic horror prose and somehow
those two styles complement each other
rather well
these are for people willing to believe
in the impossible and the impossible
will often occur however with only a few
exceptions that pay off in the later
hours the narrative choices we are given
aren't nearly intricate enough to be
worthy of said stories
the actual mechanics of the game are
also a mess the camera is a huge problem
right off the bat the freedom of motion
works fine in outdoor areas but dungeons
mines and other enclosed spaces are
claustrophobically cramped and dense
with detail and interactive items
that wouldn't be so much of a problem if
there was an easy way to just point and
click on items to investigate them or
press a controller button that swings to
focus to the next interactive item but
neither of those things exist
instead you're rubbing on tables and
shelves constantly hoping the indicator
tells you that yes you can grab the one
tiny box of ammo instead of the other
seven or eight pieces of junk you can
pick up right in front of you
there's a lot to loot in this game and
it's far too easy to miss crucial items
due to the sheer difficulty of singling
out what you need in the crush of
interactive items in the environment
you can zoom the camera in and out a few
levels but it's never the ideal place to
see everything in the area and any
enemies ahead of you without the nearest
wall also partially blocking your vision
this all has a knock-on effect on combat
on controllers the game uses a twin
stick shooter setup where the left stick
moves you and the right stick aims your
weapon a great sounding system but
because targets are smaller faster and
hit like a ton of bricks it's hard to
maneuver the camera and sufficiently
keep track of them the pc version
doesn't fix this either your character
won't shoot where you click but instead
will just aim around to that general
area the hitboxes on most enemies
require surgical precision to score
damage even with shotguns
obviously it can be done but it's hard
to be that accurate on the fly which can
frequently result in frustrating misses
there are stealthy options where as long
as you remain unnoticed you can either
do more damage with single hits set
traps using environmental hazards or
sneak up and put enemies to sleep but
the sheer number of enemies in an area
and how quick they are to notice and
investigate the slightest of movements
even on normal difficulty often make
this feel untenable for what it's worth
the basic weapon variety is nice
you're allowed to equip four types of
firearms pistol shotguns rifles and bows
along with a melee weapon and explosives
and none are restricted to a single
character so it's very easy to find your
go-to weapon type and stick with it
throughout the game
borderlands this isn't though
aside from how far and or fast they fire
every pistol feels the same every
shotgun feels the same and that applies
to all the other types too there's a
special type of explosive that drops
cluster bombs instead of doing just one
explosion but they're prohibitively rare
and expensive
that sameness isn't an issue on its own
but while weapons aren't scarce they
also don't scale
you can find a rifle that does 40 damage
on any random goon in the game with 10
pieces of silver you can upgrade that
into a rifle that does maybe 45 damage
want one that does 50 or 60 damage you
might find that difficult generally two
star weapons are the best you'll find
out in the world
although there are three star weapons in
the game they're either super expensive
the most expensive rifle in the game is
thirteen hundred dollars and doesn't
even have better damage than an upgraded
two star or they're rare money isn't
necessarily hard to come by but the
economy is heavily skewed towards
bounties above anything else you could
do for money and unless your stealth
skills are absolutely incredible so much
of your earnings end up going towards
ammo and health items to replace what
you lost chasing your targets then
fattening your wallet can feel like an
uphill struggle there is a separate
upgrade system that grants your guns
some new special abilities to learn that
makes things easier you have a max
pain-ish bullet time dive in your
arsenal when you start but all the
weapons also have special abilities you
can unlock which can now do everything
from make your next rifle shot a silent
headshot to a rampage mode that makes it
so shotguns don't need reloading every
few seconds to the ability to shoot
electric or explosive bullets
none of these are necessarily game
changers the way they should be though
part of that is the controls where
activating your weapon's abilities
involves holding toggling the aim button
holding the ability wheel button and
hoping you remember what button
activates which ability that's not the
worst control scheme on its own but
combined with how fiddly the targeting
system is using your abilities involves
clumsily fumbling around every single
surface of the controller and so even
relatively casual side quests can find
you getting into frantic endless
shootouts low on ammo and doing chip
damage the saving grace is an
overzealous quick save auto save system
that means failure doesn't put you back
too far and enough side quests and
bounties are available so that earning
enough cash for resources isn't terribly
difficult but it's typically only enough
money to maintain not advance and the
anthology nature of the game means
putting hours of work into one upgrade
that you only get to use relatively
briefly bewildering moments still occur
too
after killing one particular boss you're
tasked with destroying this haunted
mansion by placing explosives on the
building's foundation
unfortunately having used all my
explosives to kill a horde of zombies a
few minutes earlier i was out and there
was none to be found in the immediate
area this meant leaving the area riding
all the way across the country to the
nearest town with an ammo shop and
buying a stick of dynamite just so i
could finish
weird west does feel like the logical
creative conclusion to something like
fallout leaning more and more into its
western tropes
but the ultimate irony is how much this
2022 game plays like the original
fallout from 1997.
is the struggle worth it though
rather emphatically the answer is yes
the writing the story the characters and
the ways in which your actions have an
effect on the world are all enthralling
i wanted answers to the mysteries
presented since the heroes and villains
of these tales are captivating and the
payoffs by and large are worthwhile
there are a lot of excellent old-school
isometric adventure games in weird west
dna but not enough new school polish for
it to be something great
[Music]
used to be you were one of the most
feared bounty hunters in all the west
but you gave that up
buried your irons
traded them for a normal life
tonight though
that's all gonna change
destiny's calling and it ain't taking no
for an answer